you walk through the ring you walk I'm
sorry you walked through the fans to get
to the ring I do and you have some very
aggressive female fans they sometimes
grope you when you're trying to just get
to the ring to do your job there there
have been situations we I like to call
her the butt cheek bandit she you know
there's there's a lot of places I've
been touched but um she she didn't
wasn't even like a football like attaboy
you know acknowledgement it was like a
add aboard under boy
[Applause]
luckily I have security we have a great
security staff that follow me down and
make sure nothing crazy happens um but
he immediately looked at me was like
what do you think and I was like a
security guy yeah and then he goes was
it worth and she's like oh yeah oh they
kicked her out no we gave her the past
oh I'm memory there this isn't be given
a past all you ladies hands to yourself
now let me go do my job I on the other
hand if you see me walking down the
street go for it
[Music]
hi
you